the milster squealed when the plunger
went up her
blank upper sewage system you're
disgusting
wait wrong thing sorry i feel like i
don't see anyone talking about modoc
lately so let's talk about modoc why is
anyone talking about modoc you just
can't
keep this guy from talking about modoc
it's fascinating to me how quickly this
show lost relevance because i feel like
it'd be something everyone would be
talking about for at least a little
while
what little discussion i did hear of it
within the first few hours of the show's
existence before
complete silence were conflicting
reports that it was pretty good
and others that it was miserably
terrible i was interested to see how the
sense of humor worked because this
character isn't really known for being
hilarious so i decided to check it out
for myself and was surprised
to find out that the answer wasn't quite
as simple as good or terrible
it's all over the place modoc on hulu is
a stop-motion
animated sitcom about the somewhat
obscure marvel super villain of the same
name
he's a giant head and a floating robot
chair with tiny limbs and he's a mad
scientist that runs a terrorist
organization bent on world domination
and he's not really that funny in the
comics which the show adapted perfectly
by
also not being that funny oh my god the
[ __ ] ice
cream man is here holy [ __ ] okay i'm
back i got one of those spiderman
popsicles
in the show they try to humanize the
subject to debate m word
organism designed only for killing by
giving him a wacky sitcom
family of trophy characters we've seen a
million times before
such is an awkward teen boy whose father
doesn't understand his eccentricity
or a sarcastic teenage girl and an
attractive and well put together wife
that's way too good for him
over the 10 episodes of this show i felt
myself losing interest constantly had to
force myself to continue it just because
it kept
falling flat and i was desperate for it
to finally find its footing
maybe i was just morbidly curious or
some part of me also wanted it to
finally get good
i didn't want this show to be bad
because i do like the concept of an
adult animated comedy show set in the
marvel universe
deadpool got caned so this is all you
get [ __ ] i'm a big fan of variety and
that would be a really big change of
pace from the usual mcu live action
shows or the more kid-oriented animated
stuff that's on tv right now
if this show was done right it'd be a
really interesting standout among the
rest of the infinite tidal wave of
marvel based media
vomiting forth from our televisions like
arnhem zola after a wild hydra kegger
party
as the season went on i felt like it
finally started to work on
some level as a comedy and had a few
bits that definitely made me laugh or
double take
but there was still just a lot of dead
air between those where it was
floundering on just about every other
level
something about this show just didn't
work and i want to figure out
why was modoc such a misfire aim is
bought out by a shady tech company
that's run by evil space aliens and
probably
tries to monitor people's data without
their consent if anything aim is now
spying on people like you for nefarious
purposes
that's why atlas vpn is a smart choice
especially with their new 1.39 a month
deal for the first three years
atlas vpn encrypts all the data you send
but is also a great help for everyday
life you can stop space aliens and
hackers alike from viewing your personal
information with it but you can also use
it for entertainment
atlas vpn gives you access to
geo-blocked libraries on streaming
platforms such as netflix
amazon prime hulu hbo and many more if
you live abroad and want to check out
shows like modoc for yourself
it's a great choice and of course atlas
can help to avoid censorship when
traveling abroad and increase your
security on public internet connections
and get the best deals on airline
tickets and hotels
it can also block malicious third-party
links and ads
share files and download torrents
privately and securely and their new
data breach system is a major help
by inserting your email address the data
breach tool scans the internet to see if
it ended up in any recorded data
breaches or data dumps that include
emails names passwords and other
sensitive information
enabling notifications ensures that you
are aware of such incidents and gives
you heads up to change your password
before anyone has a chance to steal your
accounts
currently atlas vpn is running a huge
discount on their three-year deal for
just 139 per month
with a 30-day money-back guarantee the
deal won't last for long so make sure to
check it out by clicking the link in the
description below it helps me a lot
let's take it back to the show's roots
as of 2019 modoc was planned to be part
of a whole lineup of adult animated
comedy shows based on marvel comics
including hit monkey also known as that
really stupid concept
introduced in one deadpool storyline
that was never funny or interesting
beyond the initial absurdity of a monkey
with guns
tigra and dazzler which had some
potential just based on how interesting
dazzler's powers are
and howard the duck who is probably the
only character in this proposed plan
that an animated adult sitcom would
actually work really well for because
the comics are basically just
already that these shows would cross
over into one big special titled
the offenders ah that's funny but then
in december of that year marvel
television was brought in to be part of
marvel studios
no doubt in preparation for all the
disney plus shows with this being too
adult for disney it got pushed off on a
hulu like so many lgbt teenagers before
it
and with that merger marvel studios
decided not to do any of the other
series
leaving modoc the sole survivor of what
would have been something much bigger
and more ambitious and probably very
annoying if all of them were the same as
this one
i feel like that should have worked to
this show's benefit because now the
attention isn't spread thin over four or
five shows that are excessively
identical in presentation
the producers and writers could just
keep their big radiant robot heads
focused firmly on this one and make it
the best it could be
but the final product still lacks in a
lot of areas
the main story arc of the first season
is that modoc's organization aim has
been bought out by a big tech company
and his role as its leader is
continually reduced by an annoying new
boss
and a board of directors that are
secretly the main antagonist
this causes modoc's relationship with
his family to strain so his wife comes
to her senses and finally separates from
him until he starts to get his act
together
the show's main story arc is modoc
learning to be a better guy to his
family and trying to take his place back
at the top of aim
so he can get back on track to world
domination while he's in a rut he goes
on a few adventures that only a show set
in the marvel universe could provide
like time traveling
[Music]
assembling a team of obscure loser
villains to break into avengers tower to
impress more well-known and successful
super villains
and getting lost in the forest outskirts
of asgard with his son
these ones listed are the standouts
because a lot of the other episodes feel
like filler
don't utilize the potential of the
setting as well for an interesting or
funny story
like modoc and his family are caught in
a death trap designed by that villain
arcade who you may remember from that
marvel ultimate alliance mission
and instead of something really creative
and elaborate the majority of the
episode is spent in one
room where the trap is just to figure
out which family member is a robot
it's no secret that this show is meant
to be like marvel's answer to harley
quinn as that's a show about c-list
super villains doing funny stuff in a
more light-hearted version of the dc
universe on the surface level it's the
same basic idea but the execution is
sloppier in modoc
for one harley quinn is able to still
keep its identity strongly tied to the
characters of the comics
everyone in that show still is kind of
like
them you know some kind of clever spin
on how they are in the books
either by exaggerating their
personalities to be more humorous or
like playing off the fact that clay face
is an
unhinged failed actor or having aquaman
be a total bro
props to harley quinn for putting some
respect on aquaman's name he beats up
almost the entire legion of doom by
himself in one episode
in other cases the show can play off a
character by making them
less exaggerated than their comic
counterparts like making poison ivy feel
more like a regular person who just
happens to be a super villain on the
side but still keeping her priorities
and goals the same
it makes her a good straight man for the
more silly characters
harley quinn has its character dynamics
figured out for the best comedy
with modoc everyone from the comics
basically had their personality
thrown out and an entirely new one
created for them as
the silly wacky one that acts dumb
sometimes
and every original character created to
fill out the cast is also
the silly wacky one that acts dumb
sometimes there's not really a straight
man to bounce the absurdity off of
everyone's the quote-unquote funny one
it's like if the office was just michael
scott wearing different colored hats at
every desk
modoc is a super intelligent computer
brain that considers human life inferior
but now he's just a schlubby dad that's
a little full of himself and wants to
rule the world out of some kind of
inferiority complex i suppose the only
characters that
sort of resemble themselves are wonder
man and iron man but they're used very
sparingly and
still just kind of the dumb one i will
say
that nathan fillion as wonder man is
fantastic casting and i'm glad he got to
play him in this after his part in the
mcu was unfortunately cut
part of me wonders how this show will
play for people whose first introduction
to modoc and monica rappuccini is the
avengers game since that's their most
mainstream appearance so far
[Music]
no modoc you can't i love you i have
groceries
he doesn't have crohn's disease if
anyone has undiagnosed crohn's disease
it's me
and i do the adolescent cub turned
on me snarling frothing at the mouth
darwin bought me a few precious moments
to call for help
my dad shot the wolf i'm not gonna
[ __ ] you and say i was a huge modoc
fan and i'm annoyed they changed his
personality from the comics
i reserve that for characters i like i
really don't care that they changed him
to fit a comedy show but
i find it a little disheartening that
they made him such a boring stereotype
how many sitcoms animated or otherwise
are about an inept
insensitive dad that's always
inadvertently terrorizing his family
with shenanigans
and the fact that the family they
invented for him are so generic and
predictable
really doesn't make the show feel
special beyond the cast's archetypes
feeling played out and
unclever i think the show is weighed
down by its direction and voice acting
because
on paper i feel like a lot of these
jokes would be funny if i was reading
them as a screenplay
yet the way they're brought to life
falls flat for me about 80 percent of
the time
and now a message from our sponsors
which is
us in this case but yeah you know what i
mean if every single one of my twitter
followers donated one dollar a month i'd
be able to do this job forever and fun
bigger and better projects than ever
before
i know it's a pain in the butt but
please consider donating through the
patreon if you want my channel stick
around for a long time
and as i've tried to boost my production
quality this past year i've taken on a
whole lot of help from friends and i'd
love to be able to consistently
compensate them for all their hard work
that helps keep the channel up and
running
from my pals ben and diego helping me
edit and co-write a few reviews
molly creating storyboards for live
action projects jacob's help with
brainstorming animation color correction
and video thumbnails
and my buddy william putting in tons of
work on insane 3d
animated ideas making sure i can
continue to pay my friends and
co-workers for their creative input is a
top priority for me but beyond that we
want to expand the channel into
something bigger and one day move all of
us together into the same city and rent
our own studio so we can crank out
videos and movies and animations like a
well-oiled machine
no that would be possible without your
generous donation and your pledge will
help all of our crazy ambitious dreams
come true for again just one dollar a
month i'm reorganizing my patreon to
have a
only one dollar tier for the same
content behind the scenes videos polls
status updates and more for just one
dollar for
everyone i think we can totally make
this goal so let's do it
okay i i shouldn't even have to put in
this this aside but
i understand that comedy is the most
subjective thing in the world
and what i find funny may not be the
same as what you find funny dear viewer
i also understand that it's hard to be
funny consistently and not every joke
i tell always lands successfully so bear
in mind that while i'm talking about
this part it's entirely from
my perspective when i say the show isn't
funny or something didn't work
just put an imaginary ellipsis in the
words in the eyes of xavier or
from xavier's perspective so you don't
need to type up seven paragraphs
explaining to me that the show was
hysterical
like i get it if you liked it and i can
concede that there are some good bits
but this is an opinion piece and not a
factual data sheet based on what's been
scientifically proven to be
funny or unfunny by a team of expert
researchers in the field of funomics
god damn anyway so this shows as funny
as a cancer diagnosis most of the time
and i just watch it totally stone-faced
waiting for something interesting to
happen and then it never does
as i said on paper a lot of the humor
could work but often the delivery
kills it by the way i hope kids were not
in the picture because the crystal
you're holding is highly radioactive
definitely sterile now your balls are
completely useless purely for show
this show could really use a quick pace
where the comedy is just on full blast
and they're telling joke after joke
after joke
like uh archer that's a show where
nearly every line of dialogue is clever
or funny and the cast are so
rapid fire that even if one bit doesn't
quite land
the one immediately after that does here
there's a lot of
dead air waiting for the audience to
finish reacting before the next thing
and if you didn't react at all then
there's just this
like awkward silence it's written like a
bombastic
off-the-wall slapstick goof fest but
directed like it has a more dry sense of
humor and it clashes so hard that most
of the jokes stumble
pd has something to do with the
animation style because stop motion
doesn't allow for something as fluid and
fast as other types of animation
what modok is doing and saying is often
balls out absurd but he's doing it
really
slowly and matter-of-factly so the punch
line is easy to see a mile away
the show is lacking a certain kind of
energy that would have really helped it
feel more in your face
some of the best scenes are when it does
capture that energy and the back and
forth and the dialogue starts to have a
really dynamic rhythm
the conference call scene is by far my
favorite in the whole show because it
does have that manic energy
and it doesn't dwell too long on any one
part of the joke
it just keeps building and building and
it's [ __ ] hilarious
the other factor that drags the comedy
down for me is the voice acting
the cast of this show are all funny
people and good voice actors
full stop but i don't know if a lot of
them are fit exactly for these
specific characters patton oswalt who
voices modok
seems to have found himself a niche as
the funny animated character in adult
comedy stuff
between his role as happy the imaginary
unicorn or the stupid talking gills and
that dream sequence and the boys and a
bunch of other stuff like that
his voice is unique and fits animated
characters well
but morocc could have benefited from
someone sounding a lot more cartoony and
out there i need quiet jody my masterful
computer brain is
processing incredibly complicated oh
oh i put a paper clip in the little hole
my time machine watchy thing and
something's happening
oswald's delivery is very ordinary and
down to earth which is why he works well
as more normal and relatable animated
characters
he can also sound like a really nice and
comforting character like happy which
contrasts well with the blunt rudeness
of that show's main character
i think it's because you believe in me
fascinating
uh-huh now believe in this we break into
austin's office hack his brain before he
signs
and revert control of aim to me we're
doing a mine heist baby
but this is a role where he was supposed
to turn up his own
blunt rudeness and i don't really think
it worked he sounds too nice to pull off
the part of a lovable jerk so it isn't
as funny when he says something rude
the lovable part just kind of flops and
he sounds too normal to play such a
crazy looking and oddball character so
he's gonna do whatever he wants
at his bar mitzvah whether you like it
or not mo doc fine we'll diaper the
doves
it's just that they're buttholes shut
you're a monster
i think modoc's persona as an insane
super villain needed a voice that sounds
more naturally villainous or unhinged
or could pull off that cruelty with more
of a charisma maybe tom kenny
ha i'm not gonna lose i've got a
foolproof plan for winning
i'm gonna cheat or john dimaggio
wait that's it what's it
ow the answer is not to build myself up
it's to knock the competition down or
kevin michael richardson
let's brighten up the brownstones with
some joker white
or even alan tudyk a superhero team
i can actually get behind
a superhero team i can actually use alan
tudyk is mostly a dc guy from what i
could tell but
by god does he do a good job of sounding
like a crazy evil weirdo
because as it is modoc doesn't really
sound like a super villain
and the ordinariness of his voice makes
him sound wrong
delivering wines where he has to be an
[ __ ] to his family
magic lou why can't you just pick a
normal teenage boy theme
like sports or tugboats
when it's delivered this flatly it's
just like
oh well that's a shitty thing to say to
your son
but if he said that same thing like a
comic book super villain
it might have come off as more playful
and funny the other big drag on the
voice cast is ben schwartz who i'll say
for sure is one of my absolute favorite
sonic voice actors
and i loved him as leonardo but playing
a hyperactive 13 year old
ah he doesn't sound 13 or even anywhere
near
close to it 90 of magix in the flare
david copperfield said that
90 of magix in the hair david
copperfield's hair plug guy said that
modok's son lou is supposed to be a kid
but his voice is that of a grown man and
it just doesn't fit well
i guess schwarz's natural charisma as a
voice actor still comes through though
because eventually he started to grow on
me near the end of the season
especially after they gave his character
a robot twin so they could sort of
bounce off each other
weirdly enough just having two of that
character seem to make him a little more
unique
as much as this show fails to impress me
i am pretty fascinated by the visual
style
i love the stop-motion animation and i
know that on a technical level it took
an incredible amount of work
especially some of the more fast-paced
fight scenes that have a lot of motion
and dynamic camera movement
that's all an a-plus from me but if i
had any gripe it's that it feels like
sometimes it's a little overdone
in dialogue scenes where not as much
movement as necessary
the whole show is animated to give the
illusion that it's shot like an
unscripted documentary with these shaky
cams and quick zooms and pans
but there's no narrative element
explaining that this isn't a modoc
version of the office there's no
camera crew following the character
around or interview segments where they
talk to the camera
like look at this shot it looks like the
cameraman is walking around the car and
onto the grass to get a better look at
what's going on
and i know simulating these footsteps
must have been a colossal pain in the
ass but like
why is it there it's visually super
impressive as a gimmick but it doesn't
feel motivated by anything
other than to just flex that they could
do it they could have saved a lot of
time if they dialed back all the
simulated handheld stuff and just
focused more on character motion
the first season story ends on a
cliffhanger and i can't really say i was
happy with the conclusion
they didn't resolve as much as i would
have liked them to and we're still not
even close to completing modok's
character arc
you know learning to be more respectful
and sensitive to the people he cares
about
while it's certainly a step up from
other [ __ ] cartoon dads that learn to
be nice for one episode only before
snapping back to being a dick again next
week
it just feels like we spent 10 episodes
not really getting anywhere
in the final two episodes he comes up
with a clever plan to defeat the board
of directors that have stolen aim from
him
screws over iron man a bit then he
prepares his son's bar mitzvah
which they've been talking about all
season he got his company back and more
or less made amends with his beset upon
and
infinitely more talented second in
command monika but we really didn't see
him set things straight with his family
which was the heart of the whole season
right as he's starting to make progress
and reconnect with him
hanging out with his son being nice to
his wife and his daughter
he backslides and lets them all die in a
horrible explosion perpetrated by a time
traveling alternate version of himself
so all the progress he made throughout
the season has been set
back to even worse than where he started
if there even
is a season two it will likely begin
with him trying to use time travel to
resurrect them
but at this point we really can't root
for him anymore because he went too
far into being a scumbag and he's just
not likable as a protagonist
this show shot itself in the foot by
just not knowing how to make us care
about
modoc and it would ultimately be
frustrating if his family just forgives
him in the end
in fact the only saving grace of this
show's writing so far is that his family
have a low tolerance for his [ __ ]
and reasonably push him out for being so
toxic
it wouldn't make any sense for his
family to just let him backpedal this
if they don't forgive him the show's
just sort of over and modoc won't learn
anything
if they do they'll be too inconsistently
written to be believable anymore it's
the problem most people have with rick
sanchez always getting a pass for
abusive and shitty behavior
except modoc isn't funny and endearing
like rick sanchez
so it's even harder for the audience to
forgive him i really don't know what
they could do to save his character at
this point without it feeling incredibly
forced they wrote themselves into a
corner
i've often found attempts at making
modok a comic relief character in other
similar projects
pretty grating and this show really
didn't change that
modoc was never really meant to be a
comedy character but they keep trying to
take him to that realm
but i think he can be really
intimidating if you acknowledge the
grotesque
disgusting body horror of his design
i'd be happy to just see the character
taken kinda seriously and played
straight from now on instead of this
constant
square pegging a round hole of trying to
make him funny and endearing
i can't believe i'm saying this but the
avengers game got something right
at least this animated show didn't
unintentionally doxx anyone though
overall it's not a terrible show or
anything there's a lot of potentially
interesting stuff here but it's done in
the least
interesting way so it's just meh
i like the concept of an adult animated
comedy in the marvel universe
the animation style is really impressive
and unique and with a lot of tweaking
this could become something special
a show about an incompetent mad
scientist super villain could work if
they figure out how we're supposed to
feel about him as a character
and then sticking to that maybe
recasting some of the voices
taking better advantage of the marvel
setting and including more superheroes
and villains be recognized
ditching some of the bland original
characters and tightening up the
animation and direction
could all go a long way but i may be
asking too much
like my constructive criticism for the
show is just
just change everything about it season
one was handled clumsily and missed the
mark for what it was going for either by
playing it too safe or
by having a hard time nailing down its
tone and direction
i'm not terribly optimistic about the
show's future with the way season 2 has
been set up
so awkwardly again if that even happens
and i don't know if this show has the
legs to really persist considering it
generated
zero buzz or discussion online
even comic fans are barely talking about
it
and they love to argue about [ __ ] if you
can't even get comic book twitter
debating then you've made something
pretty stale
i like modoc better when he was bruce
[Music]
campbell
[Music]
you